HEALTH NEEDS OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
DOES ANYONE BELIEVE THAT?
NO, NO ONE BELIEVES THAT
BECAUSE IT’S NOT TRUE.
AMERICA ISN’T THE ONLY
COUNTRY WITH THE MAJOR
POLITICAL SPLIT OVER THE
QUESTION WHO COMES IN AND
UNDER WHAT CIRCUMSTANCE.
IT’S NOT THE ONLY COUNTRY
WHERE THEIR LEADERS BOLDLY
LIE TO ITS OWN PEOPLE ABOUT
THE EFFECTS OF THAT
IMMIGRATION.
YESTERDAY, FOR EXAMPLE, IN
SWEDEN, A POLICE STATION WAS
HIT BY A GRENADE ATTACK.
THAT’S MORE COMMON THAN IT
HAS BEEN, EXPLOSIVE ATTACKS
HAVE, WELL, EXPLODED IN THE
PAST FEW YEARS AS SWEDEN HAS
WELCOMED A MASSIVE NUMBER OF
IMMIGRANTS INTO ITS ONCE
FAMOUSLY PLACID SOCIETY THIS
HAS CAUSED A LOT OF EFFECTS,
SOME OF THEM POLITICAL WE
RECENTLY SPOKE TO A AN
IRANIAN IMMIGRANT TO SWEDEN
WHO MAY BE UNLIKELY AS IT IS
HAS BECOME A LEADER, A
CELEBRATED ONE IN THE PUSH
FOR TOUGHER IMMIGRATION LAWS
THERE.
WATCH.
>> WHAT IS THE PROBLEM WITH
SWEDEN’S IMMIGRATION SYSTEM
NOW?
>> SO, THERE ARE MANY
PROBLEMS THAT’S VERY HARD TO
DEFINE ONE.
BUT THE BIGGEST PROBLEM IS
THE AMOUNT OF IMMIGRANTS
THAT ARE COMING IN.
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS,
WE HAVE TAKEN IN ABOUT
250,000 ASYLUM SEEKERS.
AND FOR COMPARISON THAT
WOULD BE LIKE AMERICA TAKING
IN ABOUT 8 OR 9 MILLION
ASYLUM SEEKERS.
THIS IS PEOPLE THAT SWEDEN
PROVIDES HOUSING,
HEALTHCARE, SCHOOLING, AND
ALL THESE BIG ALLOT OF THESE
EXPENSIVE SERVICES THAT THE
SVEDA OFFICIAL WELFARE
SYSTEM GIVES TO PEOPLE.
THIS HAS CREATED, OF COURSE,
A LARGE OF HUGE COSTS IN THE
SHORT RUN FOR THE SWEDISH
SYSTEM BUT ALSO, WHEN WE
LOOK AT LONG TERM, WHAT
WE’RE SEEING NOW WITH CRIME
AND POVERTY IS THE EFFECTS
OF HAVING A VERY LACK
MIGRATION SYSTEM FOR 10, 15
YEARS AGO.
AND WHAT WE’RE SEEING NOW
WITH BASICALLY GHETTOS AND
STREET GANGS, WHICH IS A
PHENOMENON THAT HASN’T NEVER
BEEN EVEN HEARD OF IN SWEDEN
AND ALSO JIHADDISTS
TRAVELING ABROAD, ET CETERA,
THESE ARE PROBLEMS THAT ARE
NEW TO SWEDEN.
AND SWEDEN’S SYSTEM IS NOT
CAPABLE OF, YOU KNOW, IT’S
NOT CAPABLE AND IS NOT
DESIGNED TO HANDLE THESE
PROBLEMS.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN
UNEMPLOYMENT, I MEAN, IN
2006, ABOUT 20% OF THE
PEOPLE UNEMPLOYEDY
IMMIGRANTS AND FOREIGN BORN.
TODAY THAT NUMBER IS UP TO
60%.
SO.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE AN
IMMIGRANT FROM A MUSLIM
FAMILY AND, YET, HAVE YOU
TAKEN A HARD LINE AGAINST
MUSLIM IMMIGRATION, MASS
IMMIGRATION FROM MUSLIM
COUNTRIES.
>> Tucker: WHAT’S THE
RESPONSE BEEN TO YOU.
>> IF WE WANT TO HELP
PEOPLE, YOU CANNOT PUT SO
MUCH PRESSURE TO THE SYSTEM
THAT THE SYSTEM COLLAPSE
UNDER ITS OWN WEIGHT.
THE RESPONSE I HAVE BEEN
HAVING BECAUSE I’M, YOU
KNOW, MERELY PUTTING THE
STATEMENT OUT THAT IS
SAYING, LOOK, THERE IS A
LIMIT TO HOW MANY PEOPLE YOU
CAN TAKE IN, HAVE BEEN TO
CALL ME BASICALLY UNCLE TOM,
HOUSE [BLEEP] I HAVE BEEN
COMPARED TO DR..
THIS IS NOT FROM RANDOM
PEOPLE ON THE STREET.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PROMINENT POSTS AND PARTIES
AND LEFT IN NEWSPAPERS THIS
IS OF COURSE BECAUSE I DON’T
TELL THEM THE WISHFUL
THINKING THAT THEY WANT TO